[Música]
sí
bueno gracias por la presentación
efectivamente mi nombre es juanma
iturriaga y por si alguno no sabéis soy
una leyenda viva del deporte español
esto esto lo digo por dos cosas una por
la gente que no me conocéis dos por un
momento de autoestima claro porque
después de ver esto indignado saber que
este vídeo baila te da a entender han
sacado vídeos gente bueno gente que va a
venir hoy aquí pues mucho más
seguramente mucho más preparada que yo
entonces claro no viene un poquito
encogido entonces pues ese momento de
elche cuidado que de tener efectos
cuantas medallas olímpicas es bien bueno
acabo de cambiar de yo os voy a contar
una historia tan personal como la de
como la de steve jobs
acabo de cambiar de década hace dos o
tres meses
os dejo a vuestra imaginación pensar que
de cada década ha llegado y sabéis qué
bueno ha cumplido 60 años cumplidos 60 y
sabéis esta manía que tenemos
muchos seres humanos de o bien en
nochevieja igual con unas copas de más o
bien cuando cumples pues números
redondos pues el examinar un poco tu
vida decir bueno qué ha pasado cómo ha
ido todo esto y entonces pues eso dice
cumplir 60 años y empecé a revisar un
poco pues bueno todo desde mi infancia y
tal y llegué a la conclusión hombre hoy
que estoy teniendo una buena vida no fue
jugador de baloncesto durante 14 años
profesional coincide en una época con
grandes jugadores
conseguimos éxitos impensables en
aquella españa de los 80
estudió una carrera luego me contrataron
en los medios de comunicación sale en la
tele que eso siempre está bien en la
radio luego hace como 20 años me puse a
dar un poco con conferencias para soy
hasta youtube fin que digo he tenido que
suerte no que es lo que normalmente es
la primera el primer pensamiento que nos
viene si analizamos nuestra vida y nos
ha ido bien y hemos podido hacer cosas
que nos han gustado evitar la reacción
primera decir qué suerte no ahí
cuando me preguntan o quitar tu vida
pues 7 tenido suerte he tenido suerte de
poder vivir de todo todo eso de poder
hacer cosas que me han gustado me han
emocionado más ilusionado y hace como
dos o tres años me vino a la cabeza
cuando estaba en esta especie de review
me viene a la cabeza una cosa que le
escuché a rafa nadal rafa nadal hay que
escucharle siempre cuando gana cuando
pierde cuando está sano cuando está
lesionado siempre no porque lo que dice
tiene mucho sentido y él decía que la
clave la clave no estaba en hacer cosas
gustan estimulan ilusionan sino en
conseguir que te gusten te ilusiones de
emociones las cosas que tienes que hacer
que parece que es la misma frase pero
cambia completamente y cambia
completamente claro entonces dije ostras
claro tienes razón igual igual esto que
decimos qué suerte en la vida que he
tenido y cuando es igual no es suerte
igual he tenido igual hecho algo yo para
que para que pases entonces me puse a
revisar otra vez mi vida desde el
principio y me di cuenta que
precisamente yo era un buen ejemplo eso
creo es un buen ejemplo de esa
transformación de pasar de estar
esperando que la vida me emocione me
ilusioné me guste
a llegar a un punto donde creo que estoy
ahora que estoy en el punto sé que dice
rafa de de yo ilusionarme con mi vida
insisto que parece lo mismo pero no lo
es y cada la pregunta que surge
rápidamente es decir bueno y como el
acecho
pues como yo soy un hombre de deporte
pues entrenando porque esta capacidad de
la ilusión y el encontrar ilusión en
nuestras vidas que yo creo que es uno de
los grandes motores que podemos tener
para conseguir en nuestros objetivos y
para disfrutar de esta existencia que
como bien recordaba estudios llega un
momento que esto evidentemente
evidentemente se acaba esto casi es una
habilidad muchas veces pensamos que la
ilusión viene es una ciencia infusa que
hay cosas que nos hacen ilusión otras
que no
y yo creo que como tal capacidad es
trabajable es una habilidad hay ciertas
cosas que si hacemos si las entrenamos
hacen que aumenten nuestra capacidad de
expresión ar nos vale y entonces yo os
voy a contar las seis áreas de
entrenamiento que creo que he llevado a
cabo al principio creo que
inconscientemente pero después
últimamente ya muy conscientemente
y la primera básica es la mirada
hacia donde miramos yo con 22 años yo
era jugador del real madrid de la
selección española de baloncesto tenía
pasta con tres amigos en un pisito de
soltero maravilloso tenía éxito la gente
me reconocía mi vida era maravillosa
vale y un buen día venir unos amigos
míos de bilbao y una noche estábamos a
dicen 'no ya nos es igual en el segundo
gin tónic nos pusimos un poco
trascendentes y uno me dijo jo de juanma
que buena vida llevas y mi respuesta fue
cuidado que yo yo no puede ir a un
concierto porque la gente me molesta y
me pide autógrafos
99% de mi vida era maravillosa pero yo
todavía tenía la capacidad para ir a ese
1% y decir no
aquí me rasca esto me molesta en
cualquier situación yo creo de cualquier
situación que tenemos todos en la vida
tenemos luces y oscuridad
ojalá viviremos todos en la máxima luz
pero hay cosas que realmente nos
estimula y los motivan y hay otras zonas
pues más oscuras más duras más
rutinarias llamarlo como como queráis
que es muy diferente hacia donde miramos
y si miramos hacia la oscuridad el
problema es que nos incapacita mos para
mirar la luz pero si miramos a la luz
vamos a tener muchas mayores
posibilidades de poder trabajar
la oscuridad
yo pasé yo en mi época incluso ya te
digo en mi época de jugador donde tenía
prácticamente todo lo que se puede
desear teóricamente y tal todavía tenía
esa capacidad para encontrarle perros a
lo que hacía
ahora afortunadamente siempre en
cualquier situación
me pregunto bueno estas cosas son así
qué es lo que puede hacer yo con que es
donde me puedo agarrar donde puedo
agarrar para realmente tener la ilusión
suficiente para poder trabajar lo más
complicado y lo más difícil la visión es
absolutamente básica segundo punto que
viene muy bien al al lema de esta
jornada es la trascendencia es la
trascendencia yo creo que es es muy
importante como nos contamos las cosas
como nos contamos la vida como vemos
como vemos lo que hacemos había una
leyenda que me contaron hace tiempo que
no sé si es cierto y tal que sean que
había ido john fitzgerald kennedy aún a
cabo cañaveral a ver hay un lanzamiento
y se encontró con una señora de limpieza
y le preguntó bueno señora usted a qué
se dedica y le dijo la señora yo ayudo a
poner un hombre en la luna
qué dices olé pero es que es cierto es
que es verdad es que si se ponen en
huelga el personal de limpieza de cabo
cañaveral igual no lanzamos una persona
una persona a la luna
el trascender a lo rutinario el
trascender al al día a día yo me acuerdo
que al principio cuando cuando hacía
cosas así tal como decíamos no a cada
que está se dice yo no decía nuevos doy
doy charlas y de repente digo con cómo
que esas listas como que charly atrás o
sea estos estos otra cosa esto no es una
charlita esto tiene aquí y esto además
además tienen la capacidad evidentemente
yo no aspiro a cambiar la vida a todos
pero sí aspiro y cada vez que hago esto
si tengo la ilusión de que igual en
alguna de vuestras cabezas haga un clic
que os ayude que os haga mejorar que os
haga ver las fórmulas las cosas de una
forma que os pueda resultar en más más
más satisfactoria no con lo cual ese
ejercicio de trascendencia del digamos
del día a día que muchas veces
yo creo que es otro elemento también que
aumenta nuestra capacidad de ilusión la
tercera es el aprendizaje
si tenéis hijos habréis visto
seguramente a vuestros hijos en ese
momento con dos años así que todos les
regalamos esa estructura no de con con
formas triángulos cuadrados
entonces cogen los niños y coge el
cuadrado y se van al círculo y empiezan
a darle allí y no lo meten y te miran y
tú les haces te sigues y aprenderás y
tal y de repente hay un momento donde
dicen pues igual no es aquí en mis hijos
paso rapidísimo igual no hay aquí y ven
el cuadrado y de repente meten en el
cuadrado meten el cuadrado y de repente
es como se les ilumina la cara y parece
que les va a dar un ataque y te miran y
entonces dicen dame otra dame otra o sea
que listos hoy mira fíjate que eso eso
desgraciadamente con el paso del tiempo
a veces lo perdemos lo perdemos y nos
cuesta o igual o igual no no hacemos
aprendizaje consciente no yo le había
perdido yo tenía una vida tan digamos
tan sencilla y con lo que sabía me
manejaba también que lo perdí y hace 4 o
5 años me puse a estudiar chino
con un método de tal de chino y del
chino para que estás bueno pues no sé no
sé debía tener un hueco y tal es que voy
a estudiar chino y ahora me parece
flipante en tres meses tuve una
conversación media hora con una china
media hora con una china hablando a ella
a ver qué tal cómo te llamas bien lo
básico pero con una china y me acuerdo
cuando acabó estaba yo todo su lado
desde los nervios y tal pero me creía el
tío más más listo del mundo y dije
viendo ahí a estudiar más y tal sea el
aprendizaje me parece un elemento
estimulador de primer de primer orden no
se ha hecho tres cosas en positivo no y
ahora vamos con las tres cosas que hay
que evitar porque influyen negativamente
en la capacidad de ilusión la primera es
la nostalgia
la distancia que no es una cosa de gente
mayor ya lo ha visto
tú con 19 años que en una sentido de
nostalgia en primer año universidad de
cuando estabas en el cole que se vivía
fantásticamente ya tuvo este y cuando
tiene el novio que nos trabaja cuando
nosotros estaba yo solo y cuando estás
solo joven hasta que viene esta pareja
sabes decir que nos podemos entrar en
ese en ese en esa dinámica no de siempre
querer un poco lo que no tenemos y con
la nostalgia que tener mucho cuidado
porque con la nostalgia y con nuestro
pasado les hacemos unos trabajos de
chapa y pintura terroríficos yo tengo un
amigo y tengo un amigo que está
convencido que pasó una buena mili
y yo estaba allí yo estaba allí os digo
que su mili fue un horror ya estaba
deprimido se pasó de primero toda la
mili y él tiene 101 mil y fantástico
fantástico claro tú te pones a pensar y
te hace cuando pues con eso cuando
tienes 50 aves o los 40 como eran los 40
cuando los 40 como eran claro miras
atrás y ves una ves un dibujo muy bonito
pero es que no es real es que dibujo
está trucado con lo cual al pasado lo
miramos aprendemos pero rápidamente
estamos en el presente vale segundo
temazo el victimismo e la pena miento yo
ante una buena fase de mi vida era una
pena que es una pena que la pena es esa
persona la que todo lo va mal si trabaja
mucho se queja porque trabaja mucho si
trabaja poco porque se aburre sida rival
y miran qué pesados y de abajo de vida y
aquí no pinto nada que es mister lo
mismo ser ese tipo de personas
que antes de decir nada hacen
vamos a vamos a san louis university que
va a haber un exponente del nuevo así es
que tengo mucho trabajo si es que no
puede estar bueno pues ya vamos nosotros
y me quedo hoy aquí no es así es exigir
claro que ocurre yo era así
yo era si yo yo lo juro que era era un
grano perdón grano en el culo y esto lo
dicen mis compañeros está que pasa como
cambie yo cuando me di cuenta que el el
ela pena miento el victimismo el pensar
que hay una confabulación mundial para
estropear te la vida digital es muy poco
eficaz y el gran perjudicado eres tú o
sea yo por ejemplo cuando me encanta
cuando entraba en fase apenas dejaba de
respirar y decía os vais a fastidiar
ya no entrenó / no entrenó no entrenó
dejo dejación de mi responsabilidad
evidentemente yo fastidiada mi equipo
pero aquí en fastidia sobre todo el
apena miento te fastidia a ti te
fastidia a ti con lo cual si conocéis
alguna guerra total a los apenados
primero les intentamos convencer y si no
les convencemos les ponemos una silla
pero un poquito alejados y por un chico
y por último y por último lo tercero y
lo tercero es el miedo al futuro
el mega futuro el miedo todos es lógico
nadie nadie está exento en determinados
momentos el miedo a la incertidumbre que
pasa la mañana no sabemos pero que yo
creo que sí es muy importante es saber
reconocer la voz interior del miedo
todos tenemos muchas voces dentro de la
cabeza algunos demasiados
y todos tenemos y hay algunas que
conviene seguir y hay otras que no
conviene seguir tanto entonces
evidentemente en determinados momentos
nos pueda apoderar el miedo y nos
empezar a comer la cabeza está pero qué
vas a hacer pero cómo se hace pero no te
ilusiones al final igual no lo consigues
igual no te dan escrito toda esa voz y
que es inevitable tenerla pero en lo que
sí es evitable o que sí es posible es
reconocerla y decir vale vale sí sí lo
que tú digas y tal pero yo no quiero que
me domine que me domine el miedo yo os
aseguro está atestado por una sola
persona que soy yo os aseguro que si
hacéis esto
si miráis hacia la luz si dais
trascendencia a vuestro día a día
vivir sin nostalgia sin miedo y sin
victimismo y encima nos pasamos la vida
aprendiendo la capacidad que vamos a
tener y la capacidad que vamos a ver de
lo que decía rafa nadal no es cuestión
de buscar cosas que me gusten sino
conseguir que las cosas que tenemos que
hacer nos guste se va a multiplicar
hasta el infinito muchísimas gracias 15
minutos los clavos señores